Rồi mình bắt đầu buổi học luôn hả các em
lớp mình vào cũng gần đủ rồi.
Thì trước khi bắt đầu buổi học,
thì cô sẽ có thông báo chung để cho các
em chuẩn bị như các em.
Cái này cô có 1 trên tim rồi,
nhưng mà ở đây cô sẽ thông báo lại luôn
để cho các em nắm thông tin đầy đủ hơn.
Rồi.
À.
Trên E-leanning,
cô đã đưa cái thông báo về cái lịch học
này của mình vào ngày hôm nay ha,
ngày hôm nay thì nội dung của mình bữa
trước cô thông báo cho các em chuẩn bị là
các em hoàn thiện các bài tập về nhà và.
Xem trước những nội dung cần chuẩn bị còn
lại cho bài thực hành với đồ án để các em
nhóm trưởng tổng hợp lại những vấn đề
chưa rõ để trao đổi trong cái buổi học
này.
Thì hôm nay là cái buổi họp cuối trước
khi mình thi vấn đá vào ngày.
Tháng 9 năm hôm nay,
thí dụ trong bài thực hành đồ án hay là
cái phần quá trình luôn là các phần bài
tập trên lớp,
cái chỗ nào không rõ thì đại diện nhóm
trưởng các em sẽ.
Thách trao đổi với cô rồi,
cô hướng dẫn chung cho giống luôn và.
Quy định là mình sẽ hỏi vào vấn đề nha
các em, thí dụ các em,
các em phải chú ý là mình hỏi vấn đề cái
nào không rõ,
ví dụ là các em cái nội dung a thì về các
bước tiến hành thì các em thực hiện như
vậy có đúng hay chưa? Hoặc là các em.
Chưa hiểu cái bước tiến hành thì mình cần
thực hiện những nội dung gì thì trao đổi
thì cô sẽ hướng dẫn các phần đó chứ hoặc
là những cái nội dung liên quan cho 3 cái
phần đồ án chứ không phải là cô chấm điểm
cho các em luôn nha các em.
Tại vì có một số nhóm khi mà cô đưa cái
phần thi vấn đáp á,
các bạn thì hiểu theo kiểu là các bạn đưa
cái nội dung để cô chấm trước,
và cái chỗ nào chưa được để thì các bạn
về sửa để các bạn hoàn thiện thêm.
Thì những cái buổi mà trình bày chi tiết
là trong cái phần cái buổi báo cáo quá
trình cô đã dành những cái buổi đó để đọc
và định hướng bài của mình kỹ hơn.
Còn những cái còn các cái phần hướng dẫn
á thì là phần giai đoạn của hướng dẫn á
là.
Hướng dẫn cái nội dung về các bước thực
hiện và các em tự hoàn thiện thêm ha chứ
không phải là cô làm một cái bài review
cô đang review lại toàn bộ sản phẩm của
các em.
Cho đấy là hiệu chỉnh cho giúp các em
những nội dung cần phát hiện,
detect ra lỗi cho các em rồi hiệu chỉnh
định hướng cách sửa lỗi cho các em.
Cái đó là nội dung mình cần phải tự làm
để hoàn thiện và cơ sở đánh giá năng lực
của nhóm cho các em.
Thì các em nhớ chú ý chỗ đó,
lá hồi mỗi nhóm thì các em trao đổi trong
vòng 15 phút để mình có thời gian cho các
nhánh sau nữa ha.
Rồi tới cái khi mà mình làm thì mình cần
chuẩn bị những gì cho cái ngày thi vấn
đáp này của mình.
Vào ngày chủ nhật á, thứ nhất,
nội dung chuẩn bị thì em phải hoàn thiện
tất cả các sản phẩm yêu cầu trước khi báo
cáo.
Thì những cái sản phẩm yêu cầu này là ở
đâu thì các em vào cái bài tập trên lớp
thì mình dễ rồi ha,
bài tập trên lớp thì các cô giao,
những cái mở là say bên bài tập nào thì
các em phải hoàn thiện hết.
Mấy bài tập đó.
Tạo folder nhớ nha,
tạo đúng các cấu trúc phân nửa hướng dẫn.
Và khi vô cái nội dung bài tập này là khi
mà các em phân công cho các bạn thì các
em có quyền phân công sao cũng được.
Nhưng mà sau khi phân công xong rồi,
các em hoàn thiện bài tập thì mình phải
có một bài phái nô giống như bài tập
chương một phái nô vậy đó.
Và các em phải để nó là ở phía ngoài cùng.
Còn mấy cái thí dụ thư mục con em lưu trữ
giống như là bản rap với sumột với sun 2,
rồi.
Bảng làm của sexion,
một sexon 2 của các phân công cho các bạn
làm từng phần từng phần á thì các em có
thể tự lưu trong một cái fonder riêng con,
trong đó và các em tạo riêng giống như
Reference hoặc là suộc vậy đó tùy các em.
Nhưng mà cái phải ngoài phải là vai phái
nô tránh trường học là lúc mà cô chấm bài
cô mở vô cái bài tập trung một của các em
á thì các em để tất cả các file trên
trong cái fonder bài tập chương một.
Ờ rồi cái bài final thì có ghi final một
phai no 2 rồi bài man bài hông man đợt
trước cô chấm bài là có những trường hợp
những giống như vậy thì cô phải lựa rất
là cực và cô chỉ lựa theo nguyên tắc cái
bài nào đã được edit cuối cùng thì cô sẽ
lấy cái bài.
Bài đó thôi chứ cô cũng không phân biệt
được bài nào là bài chương á nên nếu mà
nếu mình không muốn bị mất điểm trong
những cái lỗi bất cẩn như vậy thì thư ký.
Nên dịch lại và các em phải dọn giặt sạch
cái bàn của mình,
ví dụ những cái nào nội dung tài liệu em
làm hết thì em tạo fonder trông con,
trong đó riêng còn cái file final thì để
duy nhất một file final bên ngoài để cô
chấm.
Hoặc là các em để nhiều quá,
có khi có những nhóm ở đây mua này thì
chắc không có,
nhưng mà nhóm môn giống như cái môn mà có
lập trình á.
Thì bắt buộc là có phải báo cáo là phải
cóp mà các bạn là phải code là các bạn
làm trên Finot Book.
Có trường học đúng là không báo cáo gì
hết thì coi như cô không có điểm.
Thì sẽ có những trường hợp như vậy nên
các em nhớ chú ý ha. Các bài tập,
mỗi bài thì sẽ có bài fan nói riêng để cô
chấm bài.
À và có trường hợp là các nhóm không có
tổng hợp final lại.
Các em lười đến mức là các em phân công
cho các bạn làm rồi các em thả đó cô độc
gì cô độc thì những nhớ như vậy là cô
xong có chấm nha các em cái này cô thông
báo trước luôn những nhóm mà không tạo ra
final cuối cùng để cô trắng và các em để
rác rải rác vậy rồi.
Mặc kệ,
cô muốn đọc sao đọc á thì cô cũng sẽ bỏ
phần đó coi như là em không hoàn thiện.
Thì tại vì có mà nó cô nói trước và có
những trường học là các em bị trừ điểm
rồi.
Các em thắc mắc tại sao em có làm mà ông
trừ điểm?
Em có làm mà em làm không đạt yêu cầu.
Rồi tiếp theo là 2 cái bài,
đó là cái bài lập trên lớp.
Còn bài tập thực hành những đồ án môn học
thì quan trọng hơn các em nhớ tập trung
hoàn thiện những yêu cầu của bài tập thực
hành và đồ án.
Thì cái này là cô có hướng dẫn rồi ha.
Thì trong cái phần bài tập thực hành thì
các cái sản phẩm yêu cầu ở đây nè.
Các em chuẩn bị kỹ,
ví dụ mình có thuyết minh đề tài xây dựng
phần mềm cho hệ thống doanh nghiệp,
slide báo cáo cho các thuyết minh phần
mềm này,
rồi cái video báo cáo của tất cả các
thành viên cho cái phần thực hành ha.
Sau đó làm tới cái đồ án quân học thì các
em vô cái pha hướng dẫn đồ án,
thì các em cũng chuẩn bị tất cả các yêu
cầu sản phẩm,
nhu cầu thuyết trình của cái phần đồ án.
Giống như đây là cái file báo cáo đầu tư
dự án hay có rồi các slide báo cáo có
video báo cáo đồ án môn học.
Và là 2 file này là 2 file riêng thì cái
nhắc lại đối với cái video độ báo cáo mà
khi mà các em làm hoàn thiện trên đây á.
Thì các em nhớ một điều đó là đây là cái
phần tại vì thi vấn đáp thì số lượng lớn
mình nhiều nên không thể nào vừa nghe báo
cáo rồi vừa vấn đáp ra là câu hỏi được
hết.
Nên mình sẽ thi vấn đáp và cô xã hội cái
vấn đề rồi cô coi cái video thuyết trình
thay vì bình thường là mình thuyết trình
xong rồi cái em trả lời câu hỏi vấn đáp á
thì bây giờ cái phần thuyết trình đó cô
cho các em quay video.
Thì cô chấm trên cái video kết hợp với
cái phần mà các em trả lời cái mức độ
hiểu, trả lời câu hỏi,
mức độ hiểu của các em khi mà các em vấn
đáp với cô.
Nên.
Bạn đã hướng dẫn riêng rồi thì thực hành
riêng và đồ án môn học riêng.
Vì và video này là video thích đại diện
thay thế cho video thuyết trình.
Nên tất cả các thành viên phải quay video.
Mở Khang để cô kiểm tra coi bạn nào báo
cáo là phần nào.
Và do cái này là cô đã tạo điều kiện cho
các em rồi thì cái phần video quay thì
các em có thể tự xử lý,
miễn làm sao các em đủ điều kiện là tất
cả các thành viên đều có báo cáo và trình
bày về phần nội dung mình làm.
Và có mã cam trong quá trình mình báo cáo
là được.
Còn kem có thể làm có 2 phương án làm.
Phương án thứ nhất là kem giống như cái
bộ mít tinh tạo bộ mít tinh là tất hẹn 1
giờ mà tất cả các thành viên đều có thể
tham gia rồi báo cáo rồi quay video lại
thôi và nhanh nhất.
Còn nếu trong trường hợp mình bệnh bận
không thể nào sắp xếp được một buổi chung
thì các em có thể phân công ở bạn là phần
nào và lên kịch bản quay á,
mở bạn quay là phần nào,
báo cáo phần nào thì các em tự quay,
tự báo cáo phần đó.
Sau đó rồi kem edit nó lại.
Và video báo cáo không nên quá một tiếng
nha các em ha cô thực chất là thường khi
mà thiếu kem thuyết trình thực tế là
khoảng 15 phút thôi.
Nhưng mà cô biết là các em coi mỗi mỗi
bạn,
nhiều bạn làm và cái yêu cầu cô cũng có
nhiều nội dung cần phải trình bày.
Thương cô cho thời gian thoải mái hơn,
nhưng mà mình làm trong khoảng tầm một
tiếng 45 phút đổ lại thôi.
Nói vào trọng tâm những nội dung mình làm
chứ tránh mình mà mình đọc slide nói,
lê thê mà nó không có vô cái nội dung yêu
cầu.
Thì nó cô không có điểm đâu các em ha nên
cái phần quay video thì các em nhớ trước
cái phần đó thì đó là cái những cái nội
dung mình cần chuẩn bị cho cái ngày 20
tháng 9 này chủ nhật ha.
Các em có chỗ nào không rõ phần này không?
Sao tại.
À dạ,
cô cho em hỏi là về cái phần video báo
cáo là chủ nhật này mình sẽ thi vấn đáp
trên cả hai nội dung là thực hành và đồ
Hán luôn hả cô?
Đúng rồi mình thi hết đi.
Bộ cuối luôn ý.
Nên các em phải hoàn thiện hết tất cả các
cái sản phẩm cho bài thực hành và đồ án
trước cái ngày khi em trước khi các em
thi báo cáo là cô không có bắt buộc trước
một ngày mà cô chỉ cần điểm trước lúc em
báo cáo ngay 18 giờ.
Rồi cái em nộp các cái chuẩn bị hết tất
cả các sản phẩm là được. À đúng rồi,
cô quên,
xách sẵn và hỏi nó là nộp bài tập thực
hành đồ án thì cũng y chang như bài tập
trên lớp.
Các em tạo cái fonder bài tập thực hành
bài tập đồ án, rồi đại diện.
Hiện nhóm Ngọc Linh lên đây.
Rồi các em upload right,
up đó các file hoàn thiện mình nên right.
Trước khi mà cái thầy tới nhóm mình báo
cáo theo vấn đáp là được.
Nhưng mà.
Và ngày thi là phải đi đủ nha,
em vấn đáp cũng phải đi đủ nha.
Còn trường hợp nào mà các em vắng thì các
em phải báo cô,
nếu cô xem xét lý do chính án thì cô sẽ
coi cái video vấn đáp thay thế cho cô bạn
đó thay thế.
Và cô sẽ có yêu cầu riêng.
Chứ ngày thi mà mình vắng là mình không
có điểm nha,
các em không có điểm phòng la cái này á.
không?
Đúng tay nắm cái yêu cầu cơ bản cho em.
Dạ, em hiểu rồi cô, cảm ơn cô.
Rồi còn giống nào chưa rõ hơn em.
Phi.
Dạ cô cái video cô vít,
ví dụ em là nhóm trưởng và em thông
Ừ
thường thì em sẽ review và có những tag
những bạn không làm được hoặc là mấy bạn.
Trễ thì em mới làm thì em nên nói như thế
nào về cái video ạ?
À, cô không mình vui lắm,
là cái ca thấy nhiều nội dung công việc
đó em giao cho bạn nhưng bạn không làm
rồi. Cuối cùng em làm đúng không?
Dạ tại vì chủ yếu là em phân tách xong
rồi em sẽ review toàn bộ á nên là thường
À.
là em sẽ không có một tách cụ thể ạ.
Để mà em nói vô con.
Em sẽ có tác cụ thể chứ,
nếu mà em là người báo cáo tổng quan thì
em sẽ là người giới thiệu tổng quan và
trình bày tại cái nội dung sẽ là lúc nào
nó cũng sẽ có cái phần đầu tiên là giới
thiệu tổng quan về các nội dung công việc.
Các cái nội dung lý chính mà các em.
Sau đó là bắt đầu là giao làm,
nhưng mà em cần vẫn phải nắm cách nội
dung mục tiêu đối tượng và các cái quy
định để mình trình bày khúc đầu và khúc
cuối.
À dạ.
Thường là cái nếu mà là chủ nhiệm đề tài
là người ta sẽ báo cáo cái đó em,
thí dụ trong đương nhiên là mình lúc mình
tham gia đề tài là mình sẽ có nhiều thành
viên,
sẽ có các thành viên tham gia cho thí dụ
về đề tài có 3 nội dung đi mình thì ai
thực hiện?
Chủ nhiệm thường là sẽ có,
giống như là cái người chủ trì của cái
nội dung 1, 2, 3.
Nếu trong các thuyết minh á,
thường lúc nào nó sẽ có nội dung,
một chủ trì là ai?
Là dung 2 chủ trì là ai,
nội dung 3 chủ trì là ai thì các cái nội
dung chi tiết về.
Nội dung kết quả sản phẩm của các nội
dung đó sẽ do cái người chủ trì nội dung
đó báo cáo.
Dạ dạ em hiểu.
Còn đối với nếu mà là chủ nhiệm kiêm luôn
chủ đề nội dung thì sẽ báo cáo luôn cái
phần đó. Còn không,
nếu chủ chủ nhiệm là người quản lý thôi
và người kiểm định cái sản phẩm cuối cùng
thì sẽ là người làm báo cáo khúc đầu.
Báo cáo giới thiệu về đề tài và.
Báo cáo về kết luận về các vấn đề mà đề
tài đã làm được rồi,
những vấn đề nào đề tài chưa làm được
hoặc là cái vấn đề liên quan khác.
Người báo cáo đầu hoặc hết cuối sẽ có cái
báo cáo đó chứ em.
Dạ dạ, em hiểu rồi. Em cảm ơn cô ạ.
Tài Minh.
Dạ.
Dạ thưa cô là nhóm em á thì các bạn chia
thì có thể theo cặp giải quyết một vấn đề
nào đó trong đồ án và thực hành đúng
không cô?
Thì không biết là lúc tụi em quay video
chung với nhau được không cô?
Ý là 2 bạn,
ví dụ như 2 bạn quay video còn cùng nói
được không cô?
Thì cũng kem cô phải phân chia ra,
bạn nào nói phần nào,
phần làm phần nào chứ không lẽ 2 em cùng
lên tiếng.
Nó vẫn có công việc tách biệt riêng của
hai bạn chứ đúng không?
Dạ.
Thì cái em giao theo cặp thì cái cặp đó
là các bạn cũng phân duy công việc nhau
làm cho một cái tag lớn đó.
Thì cái tag lớn đó bạn nào làm phần nào
thì bạn đó báo cáo phần đó.
Còn cái việc mà các em quay chung hoặc là
các em quay riêng rồi. Em nói lại á,
hồi nãy cô nói là cô cho các em quyền
edit cái video của mình,
miễn sao mình chỉnh thôi.
Rồi sao huyện.
Ờ dạ cô ơi cho em hỏi tiếp,
ví dụ như nhóm em sẽ chia ra là 5 bạn làm
thực hành 7 bạn làm đồ án thì có bắt buộc
là phải toàn bộ có mặt trong video đồ án,
toàn bộ có mặt trong video thực hành hay
là chỉ cắt phần.
Phần phần ai làm vậy phần đó nhận luôn hả?
Các em phải nhớ là thực hành đồ án là
đánh giá cá nhân cô đã dặn từ ban đầu rồi.
Và mình thực và thực hành thì mình sẽ học
được những kiến thức của bài thực hành.
Đầu án thì mình sẽ học riêng của những
kiến thức về đồ án.
Khi mình phân công và các em có thể làm
công việc riêng, tab nhiệm vụ của mình.
Nhưng mà khi mà tổng hợp lại thì các em
phải nắm công việc của.
Nhau để mình ít nhất là hiểu một cái
luồng của toàn bộ các quy trình thực hiện
và bạn nào cũng có điểm thực hành,
bạn nào cũng phải có cái kiến thức về
thực hành bạn nào cũng có kiến thức về đồ
án thì bạn nào thì phần nào cũng phải báo
cáo hết các em.
Chứ không có phân chia theo kiểu đó,
nếu mà hiện tại các em đang lỡ phân chia
theo đó thì các cái tag nhiệm vụ phía sau.
Nếu thí dụ bạn nào mà chưa có làm đúng
cái gì,
không có đóng cái thông tin bài thực hành,
hoặc là bạn nhóm nào mà chưa có nắm thông
tin về đồ án thì em phải phân công những
công việc còn lại.
Để cho các bạn chưa có tham gia vô cái
phần tương ứng để các bạn có cái nội dung
các em, các bạn báo cáo với em.
Anh địa bàn em hiểu, cảm ơn cô ạ.
Rồi vậy,
nó không có chỗ nào nữa thì đại diện nhóm.
Nhớ lưu ý này nè kem.
Thực hành
Hẹn nộp bài bây giờ sợ quên thì kem nộp
trước để kem xong rồi phân công để cho
các bạn làm rồi đẩy cái sản phẩm lên từ
từ. Ha.
Tương ứng với loại đồ án cũng vậy nha,
kem cô đã mở.
Cái phần mà bài tập ngày hôm nay các bước
còn lại là cô sẽ không giao bài tập nữa
mà là cho mình sẽ áp dụng tự hoàn thiện
và mình áp dụng thẳng vô cái bài thực
hành với đồ án của mình luôn.
Nh em.
Rồi bây giờ mình học cái nội dung chương
mới đi ha.
Sao tay.
Thì anh hãy cô có nói là phải hoàn thiện
và nộp hết tất cả các link trước khi mà
vấn đáp thì do nhóm em có bị mix cái link
của tuần trước á cô thì có thể xin mở ra
để hoàn thiện hết tất cả các link lập bài
tập được không cô?
Không phải nộp tất cả các sản phẩm trước
khi thi vấn đáp,
em là em lúc lót tất cả các sản phẩm của
mình lên cái ride cũng như mình á.
À là chỉ cần góp lên ra là đủ chứ không
cần phải là cái file ở trên e-learning
Cái file nào mix my my file nào industry
bị miss đó thì thôi,
nộp đầy đủ.
nhưng mà cái file nào chưa nộp thì phải
nộp đầy đủ nha em để cho bên trung tâm
kiểm tra nữa.
Nhạc dạ, cảm ơn cô.
Rồi mình học khóa hôm nay cái cô dạy,
cái phần chương cuối,
cái phần này là nó sẽ hỗ trợ bổ sung cho
các em hoàn thiện các cái bước của cùng
trong cái phần thực hành chế đồ án thôi.
Nó cũng không quá khó ha,
và nên ở đây là cô sẽ chỉ một số.
Nội dung quan trọng để các em có thể áp
dụng vô cái bài thực hành đồ án hoặc là
cái núi trong quá trình mình hoàn thiện
cái bài báo cáo của mình,
sau đó là mình sẽ dành thời gian để trao
đổi các cái giải đáp các thắc mắc.
Và cho các nhóm nha các em.
Thứ nhất là cái nội dung trưng bày của
mình nói về cái bảo mật hạ tầng và quản
trị rủi ro.
Đây là một trong mấy cái mục mà mình cần
phải viết trong cái dự án đầu tư.
Ngoài ra,
nếu mà bên phần mềm mà các em đang làm
các cái dự án mà khi mà các em đặt cái
phạm vi,
cái dự án của mình ứng dụng của mình
trong một số cái quy trình đặc biệt.
Thì cái phần bảo mật và quản trị rủi ro
này cũng là một trong những yếu tố bắt
buộc mà mình phải cam kết với khách hàng
khi mà mình giao dự án cho họ đó.
Thì đầu tiên mình sẽ nói về các khái niệm
an toàn,
ha các khái niệm an toàn thông tin,
thì an toàn thông tin nó là một cái.
Quá trình bảo vệ dữ liệu hệ thống dịch vụ
hạ tầng công nghệ thông tin khỏi hành vi
truy cập trái phép nè,
thay đổi bất hợp pháp hoặc là gián đoạn
dịch vụ hoặc phá hoại,
và mình phải bảo vệ được dữ liệu tại
nguyên số nè,
ngăn chặn các truy cập trái phép.
Đảm bảo hệ thống hoạt động ổn định,
giảm thiểu thiệt hại khi xảy ra sự cố bảo
mật và gắn bảo mật với các hoạt động quản
trị rủi ro luôn.
Cái này thường thường đi đôi với nhau ha.
Trước đây thì cái việc an toàn thông tin
này,
nếu mà các em để ý là các em sử dụng một
số cái website mà bên nước ngoài của châu
âu á thì khi mà đó lúc đó là người ta áp
dụng các cái quy định về an toàn thông
tin sớm hơn.
Nên khi mà mình vô một cái website hoặc
mình làm việc gì á thì người ta sẽ đưa ra
cái thông báo là họ đã xử lý các cái dữ
liệu rồi đảm bảo các dữ liệu như thế nào,
rồi cái dữ liệu này là cái.
Trong cái được trên cái website được sử
dụng dựa trên áp dụng dựa trên thỏa thuận
theo cái quy định nào thường lúc cái đó
là bắt mình nhận xét thì mình mới vô cái
website đó mình xài á.
Nhưng mà tại thường mình không để ý mình
hay nó giống như cái file rumy á,
mình file.
Quy định trước khi mình xài chấp nhận
mình xài nhưng mà người dùng thường á là
sẽ hay lướt qua cái đó.
Nhưng mà nếu mà đứng ở góc độ là người
dùng thì cũng mình cũng không có sự lựa
chọn khác.
Mình muốn sử dụng dịch vụ của họ thì mình
phải.
Chấp nhận còn không chấp nhận thì họ
không cung cấp dịch vụ vậy thôi nên
thường khi mà mình xài mấy cái trang web
này,
đối với nếu mà em xây dựng cho doanh
nghiệp và mình làm á thì đã đảm bảo cái
uy tín của doanh nghiệp thì đối với những
cái thông tin an toàn thông tin này,
em vẫn phải đảm bảo được.
Chứ cái hệ thống mà khi người ta sử dụng
cái hệ thống của em là người ta đã cung
cấp các thông tin cá nhân cho em rồi.
Các thông tin cá nhân tối thiểu bình
thường,
ít nhất là mình sẽ có các thông tin cá
nhân tối thiểu và các lớp file làm việc
của mình.
Là nó đã thể hiện hành vi cá nhân của
mình rồi.
Nên nếu mà cái trang web đó nó không an
toàn thì cái mức độ quảng bá hoặc là
người dùng người ta cũng sẽ đánh giá thấp
cái trang web đó và người ta phải đóng
phần mềm đó,
hoặc là cái hạ tầng đó thì người ta sẽ ít
xài, nó ảnh hưởng tới uy tín.
Nên cái này hầu như tất cả các dự án mình
đều phải đảm bảo cơ bản cho họ ha.
Thì một số cái ví dụ minh họa về cái
trường hợp nó không an toàn,
ví dụ giống như tài khoản sinh viên bị
đánh cắp mật khẩu nè, website,
trường học bị tấn công làm gián đoạn truy
cập và cơ sở dữ liệu để bị chỉnh sửa trái
phép thì mấy cái này là người ta không
muốn. Và nếu mà.
Cho câu các em làm các hệ thống phần mềm
và các em muốn áp dụng các công nghệ mà
liên quan về bảo mật mới hiện tại thì
thường cái phần mà các công nghệ bảo mật
mới người ta cũng đang nghiên cứu để đảm
bảo mấy cái này nè.
Ngăn chặn truy cập trái phép nè hoặc là
thay đổi dữ liệu bất hợp pháp,
giai đoạn gián đoạn dịch vụ thì một số
cái công nghệ hiện tại,
ví dụ như công nghệ blockchain đứng ở
dưới góc độ kỹ thuật thôi nha các em,
cái này các em phải phân biệt được nó với.
Hồi bên đầu tư với lại bên kỹ thuật thì ở
đây là mình là ngành công nghệ thông tin
thì hãy nhìn nó dưới góc độ kỹ thuật thì
công nghệ blockchain đứng dưới góc độ kỹ
thuật thì nó là một công nghệ mà bên cái
nhánh an toàn thông tin người ta hay
nghiên cứu khá là nhiều.
Tại vì cái mục tiêu của công nghệ
blockchain,
người ta muốn hoàn thiện là người ta đang
muốn thay đổi bất hợp pháp nên nếu mà các
em nghe một số dự án mà gọi là ứng dụng
blockchain á thì em sẽ thấy cái sự cam
kết hoặc là cái người ta miêu tả cái chức
năng mở rộng.
Của nó là đảm bảo cái dữ liệu của mình sẽ
không bao giờ được chỉnh sửa.
Có nghĩa là dữ liệu của mình đưa lên,
nó sẽ không ai giữ được chỉnh sửa.
Tại vì nếu nó chỉnh sửa thì nó hay gặp
tới cái vấn đề là cái thông tin của mình,
nó không còn minh bạch nữa.
Ai muốn sửa gì là sửa đó,
thông tin nó không minh bạch,
thí dụ cái dữ liệu đó của em là một cái
hệ thống và dữ liệu về số dư tài khoản
ngân.
Ngân hàng đi hoặc là các cái thông tin về
cái bên blockchain hay làm cái dự án này
khá là nhiều là truy vết sẵn,
truy vết nguồn gốc.
Truy vết nguồn gốc sản phẩm có thể là
nguồn gốc thực phẩm hữu cơ chẳng hạn.
Thí dụ em cung cấp một cái thực phẩm hữu
cơ,
thì em cam kết với người dùng rằng cái
thực phẩm này nó được sạch từ nơi,
nó sản xuất và trong quá trình vận chuyển
nó vẫn.
Đảm bảo các quy định và an toàn thực phẩm
đến lúc tăng người dùng,
và người dùng có thể truy vết được toàn
bộ cái nguồn gốc của cái thực phẩm đó.
Nó đã đưa đi như thế nào để người ta yên
tâm về an toàn thực phẩm á?
Thì cái giá trị đó khi mình cung cấp
website thì thật sự là website.
Size nào cũng cung cấp được,
nhưng mà cái lo lắng của người dùng là
cái thông tin đó nó có bị thay đổi chưa?
Hay đây là đúng là cái thông tin thực tế
được dette.
Trong cái quá trình mà cái sản phẩm này
được sản xuất cho đến tay người dùng.
Thì một số cái công nghệ blockchain là nó
sẽ cố gắng làm mình sử dụng cái sổ cái để
mình kiểm soát cái sự thay đổi dữ liệu
của mình.
Và ai có thay đổi cái gì thì ai cũng nhìn
được lịch sử của nhau và cái dữ liệu của
mình nó được.
Không bị thay đổi bất hợp pháp,
toàn gọi là được minh bạch bầu,
được minh bạch.
Còn nếu mình sử dụng dịch vụ của bên thứ
3 thì kem sẽ phải hiểu là.
Phụ thuộc vào bên thứ 3 ha.
Bạn nào mà học bên dữ liệu rồi thì các em
sẽ biết là em quản lý dữ liệu em sửa được
hết ha cái tiếp theo là cái gián đoạn
dịch vụ phá hoại là hệ thống của người bị
tấn công á thì nó bị dịch.
Người nó bị gián đoạn dịch vụ thì mình sẽ
mất uy tín thôi.
Khi mà các em làm cho bài thực hành làm
bài phần mềm hay là các em nói về cái dự
án đầu tư ở quy mô lớn thì mình cũng phải
xét tới cái yếu tố an toàn thông tin.
Thí dụ phần mềm thì mình sẽ áp dụng các
công nghệ mới hoặc là em phải đảm bảo.
Các cái quy định như thế nào để đảm bảo
an toàn thông tin,
còn nếu mà là đầu tư bên đồ án thì mình
phải kiểm soát,
làm sao mình cung cấp đầy đủ các thiết bị
an toàn bao mặt thông tin hoặc là có các
cái hệ thống phòng thi dựng các hệ thống
phần mềm.
À đảm bảo cái vấn đề này ha và khi về nói
về an toàn thông tin á thì người ta sẽ có
một cái yếu tố tam 3 3 trụ cột.
À,
thường cái này mình hay nghe một câu gọi
là tam giác bất đối xứng.
Là mình thường á là mình sẽ không có đạt
được.
Ba điều trong một cái tam giác như ba
đỉnh bất đối xứng này giống như là bảo
mật dữ liệu,
bảo mật và những người thông tin,
toàn toàn bảo dữ liệu không bị chỉnh sửa
nè,
sẵn sàng và đảm bảo hệ thống luôn truy
cập được.
Thì thường khi mà mình xây dựng hệ thống,
hệ thống của mình nó đạt được 2 trong 3
điều này thôi.
Hoặc là đạt 2 và cái điều thứ 3 thì mang
tính chất tương đối chứ cũng khó một lúc
mà cái hệ thống mà nó có thể nghiên cứu
thì đương nhiên người ta sẽ cố gắng là
**** muốn là đạt được hết,
nhưng mà thường là nó sẽ có sự đánh đổi
các em.
Giống như ba từ ba,
giống như ba từ mình nghe khá là nhiều
ngon bổ rẻ đó.
Đã ngon, bổ thì nó không có rẻ được.
Đảo bộ rẻ thì có thể nó không ngon.
Đó là một ví dụ dễ các em dễ hình dung
khi trong một ứng dụng công nghiệp mạng
thông tin của mình,
người ta sử dụng cái tam giác của nó xứng
này khá là nhiều,
có nhiều cái broblemch vấn đề trong một
cái quy trình thì mình sẽ có sự.
Đánh đổi,
ví dụ giống như một sự đánh đổi là một
cái hệ thống đảm bảo an toàn, bảo mật cao,
đảm bảo cái thượng toàn vẹn tốt thì
thường cái hệ thống sẽ như cái nó sẽ đậm
lên.
Không thân thiện với người dùng lắm đâu
mà nó bắt bộ,
người dùng phải làm rất nhiều thứ tại vì
mình đã,
đang muốn đảm bảo bảo mật và toàn vẹn
thông tin.
Mình bắt người dùng phải xác minh rất là
nhiều vòng.
Rồi mình có rất là nhiều vòng bảo vệ để
chạy và test thì cái hệ thống nó sẽ chậm
theo.
Nó sẽ không có thân thiện với người dùng,
còn khi mà em làm cái hệ thống mà nó
nhanh á thì cái khả năng bảo mật nó sẽ bị
giảm xuống tại vì mình không bắt người
dùng sát thực quá nhiều á.
Nó hệ nó dễ sử dụng.
Tốc độ xử lý nhanh hơn thì nó sẽ ít bảo
mật hơn.
Cái này nó sẽ làm mang tính chất đánh đổi
qua lại và thường thì người ta sẽ tinh
chỉnh cho nó phù hợp.
Thí dụ các cái quy trình thí dụ em đang
chọn cái quy trình một cái bước của em
với đòi hỏi tính bảo mật cao và nó là cái
yếu tố sống còn quan trọng nhất nhất.
Thì mình phải bắt buộc phải xử lý nó
trước và hi sinh cái góp còn lại.
Còn một số yếu tố thì nó không đòi bảo
mật cao thì mình giảm cái tính bảo mật
xuống để tăng cả nhiều người dùng lên nó
tùy theo cái hướng.
Rồi còn về tính bảo mật thì ở đây tính
toàn vẹn dữ liệu và cái tính sẵn sàng thì
hồi nãy cô nói rồi ha.
Trong cái phần phía trên,
ở đây các em có thể đặt phân minh kỹ hơn
với 3 cái tính này.
Rồi để làm cái này thường thường là kem
sẽ truy kiểm soát,
truy cập xác thực và phân quyền.
Thì cái kiểm soát truy cập là các em sẽ
có cái quá trình xác định ai được phép
truy cập vào tài nguyên nào và thực hiện
được những hành động gì.
Cái phần mà khi mà các em xây dựng hệ
thống phần mềm thì các em có nói là có
thể đưa trong cái thuyết minh của mình về
cái bước mình kiểm soát truy cập này.
Và cái cách mừng mình xác thực và phân
quyền.
Cái chiến lược xác thực phân quyền của
mình lên cái kế hoạch để người ta tin
tưởng cái hệ thống phần mềm của mình,
hoạt động tốt á,
phân quyền cho đúng nhóm người dùng được
phép làm gì ha.
Ở đây giống như là một cái ví dụ cơ bản
về các cái quyền mà thường là người thay
cái vai trò.
Vai trò khá là nhiều.
Và ngoài ra là nó đã an toàn rồi thì mình
phải có chiến lược backup sao lưu dữ liệu.
Cái này là thấy tiếng Nhật 3, 2,
1 khá là nhiều ha, có 3 bản sao,
2 là thiết bị lưu trữ khác nhau và một
bản sao đặt vào hệ thống chính hoặc là
trên cloud.
Cái này nó giống như kem đi xử lý đối với
các dự lực cá nhân thì em cũng cần phải
làm cái này.
Những dữ liệu quan trọng thì nhớ luôn
nhiều nơi để có lỡ có gì thì mình khôi
phục lại được.
Thì đối với các dữ liệu của doanh nghiệp,
khi em đầu tư hạ tầng thì em cũng phải,
nếu mà em có đầu tư cái thiết phần cứng.
Lúc mà phần mềm á thì các em còn hay là
các em đầu từ cái lớp liên quan tới dữ
liệu á thì các em phải có cái tính tới
cái chiến lược này.
Và mình phải mua thiết bị đủ,
có phải có server lưu trữ đủ nha kem chứ
nó mất rồi mà mất luôn á là.
Là cái này là mình phải làm thuận cho
người ta đó nha ha.
Rồi tiếp theo là cái chiến lược cập nhật
và phá lỗi trong bảo mật thì cái này mình
biết thêm ha,
cái phần này thì trong cái đầu tư,
trong đầu tư thì mình chỉ đưa ra cái
chiến lược và viết trong cái báo cáo về
cái.
Ngược cập nhật và phá lỗi để mình ước
lượng cái chi phí bảo trì,
bảo trì vận hành cho cái hệ thống đầu tư
của mình thôi.
Rồi và ở đây là cô có giới thiệu cho các
em một số rủi ro phổ biến và nguyên tắc
giảm thiểu thì đây là một số cái rủi ro
phổ biến ha về các cái phần mềm độc hại.
Cái này thì.
Nếu mà bên nhóm nào mà nằm bên an toàn
bảo mật thì các em sẽ coi với ví dụ chắc
cái phần mềm độc hại thì các em phải tìm
hiểu về các giải pháp phần mềm chống mã
độc.
Và các em có thể mua bản quyền và các em
xét nó vô cái chi phí đầu tư hạ tầng ban
đầu.
Đầu tư hạ tầng ban đầu để chống các cái
phần mềm độc hại này ha rồi cái còn có
thể hiện thực chống lừa đảo nhằm cách
đánh cắp các thông tin nhạy cảm thì cái
này là mình biết gì nó thôi chứ trong cái
dự án đầu tư thì mình không có làm cái
quan tâm cái này.
Cái này dành cho người dùng.
Giống như là không các email mà có cái
thông tin bất thường, có đường link,
đừng có nick bậy.
Nói chung cái này là sản xuất của người
dùng khá là nhiều thôi.
Email không từ cái nguồn cơ quan chính
thống thì không nên phản hồi và không nít
được link của nó thôi nha.
Còn cái tiếp theo là cái phần lộ cái dữ
liệu của em thì cái này liên quan tới
phần mềm,
những cái ví dụ trong cái hệ thống phần
mềm mà em liệt kê,
mình cam kết cho người ta thì em phải.
Thực hiện cái cam kết này trong cái
phương pháp triển khai của em khi em nói
em xem phương pháp triển khai á thì về
cái giải pháp bảo mật thì em cũng có lên
chiến lược mã hóa và kiểm soát quyền truy
cập vào mã hóa các thông tin dữ liệu quan
trọng.
Rồi phương có phân loại,
mình có miêu tả kỹ để cho người ta tin
tưởng rằng là mình có khả năng triển khai
và khi hệ thống mình triển khai ra an
toàn trong hệ thống phần mềm.
Về cấu hình sai,
cấu hình sai là cái này là cái mình phải
có cái checklist để mình tiến hành cấu
hình mà khi mà mình triển khai thực tế.
Còn ở trong cái thuyết minh đề tài đâu án
đầu tư á thì mình có.
Thể chứng minh mình có thể đưa cái tiền
vô cái minh chứng cho người ta là danh
sách cái danh sách các cấu hình mà mình
thực dự kiến triển khai cho người ta và
mình đã check cho họ về cái.
Ờm.
Về cái thứ nhất là cái mức độ phù hợp của
cái việc cấu hình của mình đối với các
thành phần còn lại và nó có thể có cơ chế
kiểm tra mặc định và mình cập nhật cấu
hình thường xuyên trong khi quá trình vận
hành.
Đưa ra để cho họ biết cách quản lý,
rồi còn cái đây là một số cái nguyên tắc
giảm thiểu rủi ro ha là các nguyên tắc cơ
quản như là cấp quyền bảo vệ nhiều lớp,
rồi không mặc định tin cậy bất kỳ người
dùng hoặc thiết bị nào.
Luôn có kế hoạch giao lưu, khôi phục,
cập nhật phá loại thường xuyên,
giám sát và ghi nhận hoạt động hệ thống,
nâng cao nhận thức của người dùng thì cái
này là tổng hợp lại mấy cái ý mà mình đạt
phía trên trong quá trình xây dựng cái dự
án cho họ thôi.
À, cái bảng này kem có thể tham khảo nè,
thí dụ cái bài của em có đầu tư cái lớp
về liên quan tới dữ liệu hoặc bảo mật,
thì các em có thể đưa ra cái đánh giá ban
đầu về cái.
Phạm vi quy trình của họ và mình có cái
biện pháp.
Các biện pháp khắc phục và dựa trên mấy
cái biện pháp này để mình.
Đưa ra cái chiến lược đầu tư phần cứng
như phần mềm tương ứng.
Và các giải pháp bảo mật tương ứng.
Rồi còn này nó cái bài tình huống thôi,
cứ không có gì quan trọng.
Rồi đây,
ở đây là một số các cái nội dung cần quan
trọng cho cái nội dung trưng bày này.
Thì các em có chỗ nào không rõ không?
Các em.
Rồi thì mình tới cái nội dung tiếp cuối.
Cái phần dương sau thì có mấy cái nội
dung mà các em có thể tham khảo,
đi vô cái báo cáo quên đồ án của mình
được hơn.
Rồi cái phần một số các cái bút quan
trọng trong cái phần đề xuất dự án,
còn đây là quy trình 5 bước giống như là
các em phải xác định nhu cầu phân tích
các ràng buộc,
xác định các tiêu chí đánh giá rồi đề
xuất phương án.
Mà đã kế hoạch triển khai cái này là nhắc
lại cái bài tập virus mình đã làm rồi nên
cũng không có nói qua nói sao nữa.
Mình sẽ đi thẳng cái phần mà các em có
thể tham khảo ở đây là từ cái phân tích
ràng buộc á,
dựa trên những cái phương thức ràng buộc
để em đưa ra lập luận để xây dựng các
tiêu chí đánh giá và các hai nội dung này
cần phải.
Có sự liên kết với nhau và thường do cái
này mình tự làm nên mình sẽ cần phải tự
xây dựng cái tiêu chí đánh giá nếu mà các
công cái mình xin kinh phí ở một nơi mà
người ta có quy định rất là rõ ràng luôn.
Về các loại sản phẩm,
về mức chi phí cho từng loại sản phẩm.
Rồi các tiêu chí mà họ đánh giá em có đạt
sản phẩm đó hay không.
Ví dụ nha,
ví dụ giống như đề tài bên bộ khoa học
công nghệ,
kêu gọi cái dự án nghiên cứu khoa học cơ
bản thì trong cái quy định nghiên cứu
khoa học cơ bản của họ thì đây là nghiên
cứu khoa học cơ bản thì mục tiêu là.
Thực phẩm là ra các công bố khoa học,
các loại công bố khoa học,
cái sản phẩm mục tiêu họ đạt tới là họ
đặt ra cái sản phẩm mục tiêu của mình cho
họ **** muốn luôn và có các loại công bố
học như là tạp chí quốc tế ISIQ,
một sẽ được trả giá bằng khoảng.
Chi phí khoảng bao nhiêu rồi các tạp chí
coi bước 11 thì như thế nào rồi we 2 là
như thế nào?
Quy 3 như thế nào thì người ta sẽ đưa ra
cái mức chi phí và cái quy định đánh giá
cụ thể luôn sau đó rồi các cái nhóm lĩnh
vực đầu tư.
Là các thành phần mà họ muốn đầu tư cái
tài ngành công nghệ mà họ muốn đầu tư thì
họ sẽ click ra luôn.
Và nếu cái dự án của em vào thì em phải
đi theo đúng cái tiêu chí của họ,
thí dụ họ có cái loại sản phẩm nào?
Mà là thí dụ ở đây của mình là mình mình
tự giá là họ còn thiếu cái gì thì mình sẽ
đầu tư thêm, phát triển thêm cho họ.
Giống như là đầu tư thêm phần cứng,
phần mềm nào.
Còn nếu mà đối với cái dự án kiểu như vậy
là họ đã đưa ra cái sản phẩm họ **** muốn
rồi thì mình phải theo cái sản phẩm của
họ thôi.
Và khi mình làm đúng cái hướng công nghệ
của họ rồi thì và với các công nghệ đó
thì họ bắt buộc phải có một công bố.
Với cái tiêu chí là Asian quy một thì
mình phải lên cái xếp hạng tiêu chí A
thôi A quy một thế nào là tạp chí Asian
quy một.
Có những cái quy định gì thì mình phải
thỏa nó ra.
Rồi họ có quyền được rồi thì mình cứ đi
theo cái tiêu chí đó,
chung mà mình sẽ vẫn lập cái bảng tiêu
chí rồi mình cam kết các sản phẩm của
mình sẽ phải đạt được tiêu chí gì để mà
xin kinh phí bao nhiêu cho phù hợp ha.
Còn đối với các dự án của mình là mình do
mình làm doanh nghiệp và các doanh nghiệp.
Ở đây mình đang giả lập mà mình xây dựng
để hoàn thiện hơn cho họ thôi nên nó
không có cái quy định rõ ràng nên mình
phải tự xây dựng cái tiêu chí nên ở đây
các em phải tự cái tiêu chí thường trong
trường hợp như vậy thì các em sẽ xây dựng
theo các cái tiêu chí của các đội đo kỹ
thuật.
Mà mình đã nghiên cứu sâu hoặc mình làm
trong cái vấn đề đau này rồi,
hoặc là trong cái quy trình này nó có các
tiêu chí này thường,
người ta dùng thì mình sẽ áp dụng các cái
loại đo tiêu chí kỹ thuật đó để mình làm.
Và có những cái tiêu chí nó sẽ mang tính
chất định tính và định lượng,
định lượng làm nó có số đo là cụ thể.
Giống như của trực trước có một số nhóm
các bạn báo cáo,
các bạn có sử dụng một số đo định lượng
và cách đo đó.
Thì đi theo đúng công thức đo lường toán
học của nó thôi,
còn ngoài ra sẽ có một số các cái tiêu
chí định tính sau này bên phần mềm khá là
khá là nhiều nha các em.
Thí dụ như bên phần mềm á,
nó khi mà người ta kiểm duyệt phần mềm,
người ta hay kiểm nhiệt là coi.
Nó có đủ chức năng hay không?
Chức năng có đạt được yêu cầu của người
dùng hay không rồi mình sẽ định nghĩa thế
nào là đạt đạt thí dụ ở đây là các cái
mức,
mức khăn đo 5 cấp độ hay dùng thì thấp
rất thấp,
trung bình mình sẽ có những đạt những bao
nhiêu tiêu chí thì thỏa thuận.
Các mức yêu cầu của sử dụng thì những cái
cách đo lường kiểu này người ta gọi là đo
lường mang tính chất định tính.
Ở bên bà thực hành với bà đồ án của mình
sẽ phải sử dụng khá nhiều cái này ha.
Nhưng mà khi các em đưa ra các phương
pháp đo lường này thì các em phải có sự
liên kết giữa cái đoàn bộ phía trên và
các tiêu chí ở dưới.
Rồi cái thằng đó cấp độ 5 cấp độ này,
em phải miêu tả làm ý nghĩa của thằng đo
nâng cấp độ này.
Để có một cái số liệu đo lường cụ thể để
mình thanh ta gọi là nghiệm thu hợp đồng
và thanh lý thanh lý thanh lý là mình làm
không được rồi mình phải thanh lý hợp
đồng rồi mình trả tiền đồng cho anh ta.
Còn cái này là mình nghiệm thu hợp đồng.
Muốn nghiệm thu thì mấy cái xong số nó
phải rõ ràng.
Đấy lúc mà mình đi nghiệm thu mới nghiệm
thu được.
Thế nó không rõ ràng thì nói chung là sẽ
dẫn đến tranh chấp nên ở đây cái em ở đây
cô có gợi ý một số cái tiêu chí thường
hay dùng vào cái thang đơn 5 cấp độ.
Ở thang đo theo khảo sát thì thường kiểu
định tính cái này nó có 2 loại mà thường
sử dụng thường xuyên nhất mà em hay dùng
trong mấy cuộc khảo sát á.
Thí dụ mấy nay mà em hay được đưa mấy cái
linh khảo sát á thì em sẽ thấy người ta
hay dùng mấy cái thang đo này nhiều lắm
luôn á là thang đo 3 cấp độ hoặc 5 cấp độ.
Nằm cấp độ lại kiểu này nè và 1 sai xa 4
sao mấy trang thương mại điện tử cũng
dùng thang đo 5 cấp độ.
Rồi ngoài ra cũng có nguyên cái đơn giản
hơn thang đo 3 cấp độ như là đẹp,
trung tính hoặc là không đạt.
Kiểu gì vậy, dùng cái nào tùy mình,
nhưng mà thường thanh đo nâng cấp độ sẽ
được đánh giá cao hơn 3 cấp độ.
Ví dụ giống như cái phần đề xuất phương
án triển khai mình ở đây mình rất nhớ
mình có 3 loại phương án triển khai đúng
không? Thì khi.
Mà mình đưa ra cái mình đi khảo sát hết 3
phương án và mình đề xuất cho người ta
nên sử dụng theo các phương án nào.
Thì em phải coi các tiêu chí kỳ vọng mà
khách hàng muốn đạt tới và em đánh điểm
tính điểm của nó.
Cái nào điểm cao nhất thì mình chọn nó
thì nó sẽ có cơ sở rõ ràng hơn là mình
dùng lời nói.
Em nhớ mấy cái này là phải có tiêu chí rõ
ràng vậy em.
Ngân
Cái nhưng mà tiêu chí ở đây là ở đây là
mình đang làm giả lập nên cái tiêu chí do
cái em quyết định,
thí dụ em già đang giả lập là nó phải
theo trong cái quy trình em khảo sát thì
cần cái tiêu chí nào?
Còn nếu mình làm thực tế thì khách hàng
sẽ giao các tiêu chí cho mình quyết định,
tiêu chí mình phải làm theo cho họ.
Rồi,
các bước mà thường lập kế hoạch triển
khai là thường lúc nào nó cũng sẽ có một
cái bước từ khảo sát, thiết kế,
triển khai, kiểm thử và nghiệm thu.
Bên phần mềm cũng vậy,
phần mềm thì nó hơi.
Nó tương tự nhưng mà nó sẽ có là đi theo
quy trình phát triển phần mềm cũng có là
khảo sát thiết kế triển khai cài đặt.
Nếu mà trong triển khai đạt thì có cơ chế
SM front-end xong rồi kiểm thử rồi cũng
nghiệm thu.
Có mấy cái giai đoạn đó thôi.
Rồi đó là các cái bước quan trọng mà cô
có thể gợi ý cho các em khi mà các em có
thể sử dụng,
đánh giá và mình làm cơ sở định tính và
định lượng khác nhau để các em giết cái
thuyết minh của mình có yếu tố thuyết
phục hơn.
Không phải là một loại cam kết nói xuông.
Cái mấy cái thuyết minh mà cái mà chỉ có
lời cam kết nói suông vậy bị đánh rớt lắm
nha em.
Đương nhiên là lúc mà đến việc đề tài nó
sẽ có nhiều yếu tố,
nhưng mà nếu mà chị nói, yếu tố về thiên,
về yếu tố và chất lượng thì cái thuyết
minh nào mà nó không rõ ràng như vậy,
thường thường nó sẽ bị đánh rớt.
Rồi đó là các cái nội dung quan trọng
cuối cùng các em có thể sử dụng để các em
làm cái này ha.
Hoàn thiện cho các bước tiếp theo của bên
thực hành những đồ án của các em.
Là cái này.
Thí dụ bên đồ án môn học thì mình.
Để cô coi cái bước bài tập giai đoạn 3 là
mình còn mấy bước này ta.
Tự nhiên anh bước 9,
bước người 1 2 là cái quản trị rủi ro là
cái hồi nãy cô nói.
Rồi cách tổ chức dự án theo các giai đoạn.
Hồi dựa trên đó thì mình có phương án và
kế hoạch nghiệm thu là nó sẽ dựa vô cái
tiêu chí cam kết camera cam kết.
Tính về lượng của mình á.
Cái này là hai cái này là các em có thể
giữ trong mấy nội dung kia để các em chọn
ha,
còn cái hai cái phần mày tập ngày hôm nay,
chương 7 chương 8 thì các em có làm cơ sở
để các em có thể làm lớp 9 với 4 người á.
Cách nguồn tổ chức dự án theo giai đoạn
như thế nào?
Là đó là cái bài bên đồ án môn học,
còn đối với cái bài thực hành cũng tương
tự thôi.
Thực hành thì cái phạm vi nó nhỏ hơn
thường đơn giản hơn.
Nó cũng có quản trị rủi ro này,
kế hoạch vận hành bảo trì,
nghiệp vụ đánh giá thôi,
các giai đoạn mình làm.
Rồi cái chỗ này,
các em có chỗ này không rõ hơn các em.
Về nội dung thực hành, đồ án môn học,
một quá trình.
Họ nếu không có chỗ nào không rõ thì mình
tới cái giai đoạn tiếp theo của buổi học
này ha là trao đổi với đại diện các nhóm.
Nhờ nhóm nào có thắc mắc muốn trao đổi
các em.
Về các sản phẩm thực hành đồ án để mình
chuẩn bị cho cuối tuần này mình thi nè.
Đòi lọc sao em.
Ai cô ơi,
tôi âm hỏi về cái dom video mà giúp mình
tôi nhá thì.
Em nói lại cái mic,
cái mic của em nó rè quá,
con nghe không rõ, em nói là anh.
Cô của người đó hơn cho cô ấy.
Ờ rồi được hư rồi em.
À, em hỏi cái cái.
Thì hôm mà cuối tuần anh sẽ thi ấy,
cô thì mới đầu thì đóng trưởng sẽ nói về
tổng quát đề tài xong rồi là từng thành
viên sẽ thuyết trình cái phần phần làm
của mình.
Xong rồi là từng nhóm sẽ kết luôn là để
cái video rồi mình kết thúc rồi mình thôi.
Ừ,
nhưng mà các em phải có cái kế hoạch mà
video.
mình trình bày,
không phải làm theo các bước ha.
Sẵn bạn em hỏi thầy cô đó luôn á,
ở đây cái lỗi của các nhóm á trước đây á.
Các em phải hình dung mấy cái hiệu các
cái.
Bài tập thực hành bài tập trên lớp á của
hướng dẫn các em các bước làm thì đó là
các bước để các em tạo được cái input đầu
vào để em viết tạo ra cái sản phẩm thôi.
Nhưng mà sau đó là các em phải tổng hợp
lại và mình phải trình bày cái sản phẩm
một cách hợp lý.
Theo trình tự chứ không phải là mình chỉ
ráp mấy cái bước nó lại với nhau một cách
thô sơ. Nên thí dụ,
ở đây đối với cái thuyết minh,
cái này thì tùy theo mỗi nhóm,
có mỗi cách trình bày khác nhau.
Cô không có ép chặt khuôn, cái chỗ này,
cái này là cho các em để thể hiện cái khả
năng trình bày thì có nhiều nhóm sẽ có
những cái cách trình bày khá là hay nhưng
mà cô cũng sợ là có cái nhiều nhóm không
chưa có kinh nghiệm á.
Thầy cô cũng có gợi ý một số cái khung
thứ tự trình bày của một cái thuyết minh
tin bài thực hành này.
Và bên thí dụ ở bên đồ án môn học là cái
này.
Cái này,
cái này là em bên sinh viên là em muốn
học là cái này.
Cái khúc cuối có cái dự kiến,
cái mục luật để cho các em một mẫu nguồn
lực gợi ý.
Thì các em sẽ phải tổng hợp các cái nội
dung.
Thực hiện ở các bước rồi mình viết lại
thành một cái báo cáo dự dự án đầu tư
hoàn thiện theo cái mục này chẳng hạn.
Sau đó,
bạn nào làm cái mục nào thì các em phân
công theo các mục này để cho các bạn báo
cáo.
Chứ nếu mà mình đi theo các bước mà mình
trình bày, đôi khi nó sẽ bị lộn xộn.
Hiểu có nói không em lòng?
Em cảm ơn.
Dũng.
Dũng ý cứ mở mắt.
Dạ dạ, cô có anh em nói.
Nào nghe nói.
Dạ em muốn hỏi là cái về cái video báo
cáo của cô là ví dụ trong nhóm em là có
Ừ.
thống nhất là sẽ quay một ngày nào đó,
ví dụ thứ 2 đi nhưng mà.
Các thành viên mà không đủ,
không có mặt đủ thì sao cô?
Tại em nghe của nó là lấy điểm cá nhân
theo thực hành với đồ án á thì người
không có mặt đó sẽ không có điểm đúng
không cô?
Ờ đúng rồi,
em không có quay video là không có điểm
nên hồi nãy cô có cho các em 2 phương án
đó.
Một là nhanh nhất đó và các em đỡ phải
edit lại là các em tạo một cuộc họp rồi
cho tất cả các bạn Jondu, rồi quay chung.
Một lượng còn không,
ví dụ mà giả sử nhóm em có nhóm có một số
một nửa nhóm là tập trung thì các em quay
chung.
Còn có một nửa nhóm không có phần bạn nó
báo cáo,
bạn không có lên được và giờ đó thì bạn
đó có thể tự quay riêng.
Bạn đó gửi sượt cho em rồi cái em edit
cái video về cái thức,
cái vô cái đúng cái thứ tự về cái nội
dung bạn nói báo cáo trong cái video.
Và cuối cùng,
nhưng mà phải tổng hợp lại một cái video
final nha các em sẵn đây.
Đợt trước cũng có một nhóm các bạn không
có xếp được lịch chung với nhau,
các bạn báo cáo riêng.
Cái nhóm đó là 6 thành viên,
các bạn quay đường xá, cái video rồi.
Rồi lúc này không có gom lại luôn nha.
Rồi cô phải mở từng cá lên cô coi.
Và mấy bạn lại không phải coi,
mà phải coi để coi.
Tại nó có cái thứ tự trình bày mà.
Nên lúc mà cô mở thì cô phải đi được kiếm,
còn cái nào là của cái đoạn đầu lần nào
đoạn giữa nào đoạn tiếp theo á nhóm nào
mà làm kiểu đó là cô trừ điểm chứ nha thì
cũng có điểm chấm thì các em cũng có quay
nhưng mà các em làm như vậy là không đạt
yêu cầu.
Là bình thường điểm đó nha,
nên các em có quay riêng,
quay chung gì cũng được.
Cuối cùng phải có một cái final video
hoàn thiện.
Rồi cô mở lên cô coi cái video báo cáo đó
là cô chấm chung một lần.
Dạ, cô ơi,
ví dụ mà cái bạn mà không có mặt đó mà
cũng không quay video luôn thì sao cô
không quay video gửi riêng cho em để em?
Thì em báo cô.
Thì em bảo cô là cô không tích điểm văn
đó.
Chàng.
Dạ, cảm ơn.
Nếu ứng.
Thành viên của mình,
thí dụ các bạn trong quá trình điện ngành
thực tế,
các em cũng biết mà là có người không làm
thì ra khỏi nhóm thôi, không có điểm.
Khang.
Dạ,
thưa cô thì nhóm em là nhóm 8 mới có một
Em.
bạn tên là Hoàng Phước Thiện thì bạn đó
rút hồ sơ học rồi đấy cô nên nhóm em rồi
bạn đó ra khỏi nhóm rồi.
Hoàng Phước Thiện à.
Hạnh phúc thiện, vân vân,
vậy đi cô lên sức luôn à, đúng rồi.
Hình như cô nhớ không nằm,
cô có nhiều tại vì cô nhiều nhóm lắm,
nhiều lớp lắm nên cô không rõ.
Cô nhớ hình như có bên mình cũng có một
vài bạn đợt này là bạn có cập nhật,
thay đổi nhớt thì là bạn nào rồi cô nói
cô.
Nó luôn nha, cô cập nhật luôn bây giờ.
Thiện nhóm máy là bạn này ấy hả?
Dạ, nhóm 8 ạ.
Cô Thiện của nhóm 8.
Dạ Hoàng Phước Thiện ạ.
À bạn này đúng không?
Bây giờ bạn này sẽ không còn.
Dạ đúng rồi.
Sẽ không còn của nhóm 8 nữa thì tại 11
nhóm.
Với về phần về phần thi vấn đáp thì khi
mà mình show cái bài thuyết định của mình
Một thành viên.
lên thì đến phần ví dụ như là từ đầu đến
cuối thì đến phần nào thì bên giám thị sẽ
hỏi.
Đến phần đó rồi người làm phần đó sẽ trả
lời đúng không cô?
Không có em, cô muốn hỏi chỗ nào câu hỏi.
Ờ dạ rồi, anh cảm ơn.
Ừ, video cô sẽ coi riêng,
còn tới lúc mà cô hỏi là cô sẽ hỏi những
nội dung quan trọng và những nội dung mà
cô muốn biết là em hiểu được tới đâu thì
cô sẽ hỏi chỗ nào cô hỏi và các em có thể
các em sẽ cùng nhau trả lời.
Rồi ha em cùng nhau trả lời.
Rồi minh mẫn.
Minh mẫn.
Dạ giống em nhóm 5 có bạn Minh Trang cũng
rút hồ sơ học rồi cô giúp em cập nhật
Hàng bạn trai nữa em nhóm 5.
thông tin.
9 năm.
Là Nguyễn Minh Trang là đúng không?
Dạ đúng rồi.
Thì giờ nếu mình còn 9 thành viên đúng
không em?
Dạ, đúng rồi con.
Rồi cô cập nhật rồi,
các em lên lên kiểm tra lại ha.
Rồi còn có nhóm nào thay đổi hành viên
nữa không?
A bằng phi sao em.
Dạ, cô ơi,
không biết là cái điểm quá trình mà các
bạn trong nhóm làm á thì em có tính điểm
lại thì không biết là mình có dựa vào đó
để tính không cô?
Và các em có cái bảng phân công công việc,
đánh giá mức độ đóng góp của từng thành
viên theo các bài tập trên lớp và thực
hành và đoàn án.
Xong đó là kem sẽ đánh giá cái quá trình
y chang như vậy,
Dạ.
thực hành đồ án thì luôn theo mức độ đóng
góp của các bạn.
Ở đánh giá được thực hành với đồ án riêng
hả cô? Tại vì em đang đánh giá.
Đúng rồi, 3 cọp, 3 cọp riêng,
3 cọp riêng thì bây giờ mình tách riêng
Dạ.
ra đi em mình anh nhớ cá nhân.
Dạ dạ dạ, em cảm ơn.
Nhật cô ơi,
cái phần quay video là thực hành là giới
hạn 1 tiếng và cái đồ án giới hạn trong
vòng 1 tiếng đúng không ạ? Hai cái hai.
Đúng rồi em, đúng rồi em.
Dạ với lại là khi vấn đáp á là cô gọi tên
một bạn và hỏi bất kỳ một đề tài nào
trong cái phần đó và bạn phải trả lời hay
là mọi người có trong nhốt,
có được hỗ trợ nhau không ạ?
Bình thường là cô sẽ hỏi chung và các em
hỗ trợ trả lời,
nhưng mà có nếu có trường hợp nào cô cảm
giác là có gian lận hoặc là nó không đúng
thì cô sẽ chỉ định ít cho anh hỏi nha.
Dạ nói chung là cô bán gấp thì cả nhóm
được trả lời,
Ừ.
còn khi cô chỉ đích danh thì bắt buộc bạn
đó phải trả lời.
À đúng rồi em.
Dạ vâng, em cảm ơn cô.
Hiện.
Dạ,
cô cho em hỏi là em thấy cô có nói là
trình bày cái phần thuyết minh thì cái
thuyết minh này em cũng sẽ trình bày
Ừ
thành một cái dạng giống như báo cáo đúng
không cô?
Với lại câu thứ 2 em muốn hỏi là dựa trên
cái kinh nghiệm chấm của cô á thì cô có
cho tụi em là cái khoản mà tối thiểu tối
đa của cái độ dài.
Của báo cáo và thuyết minh trong cô để
tụi em có thể cân đo viết cho nó phù hợp.
À, cái thuyết minh này của mình,
nó là nó cũng là file báo cáo đó các em
báo cáo thì cũng viết dạng file word thôi,
nhưng mà nó là nó sẽ ghi là thuyết.
Nó không phải ghi là báo cáo đề tài mà là
ghi là thuyết minh đề tài.
Dạ.
Ví dụ,
ví dụ đây là một cái form thuyết minh đề
tài của Đại học Quốc gia.
Thì nó có cái mẫu phương gồm có 3 phần
chính là ta có cái trang bìa.
Xong rồi có cái là 01A là các cái nội
dung chung.
Thế là em sáng em thuyết minh đề tài khoa
học công nghệ đó.
Thì nó cũng là file báo cáo file word để
mình mình viết thôi.
Nhưng mà đây là thí dụ ở ví dụ của đại
học quốc gia hoặc của bột,
có công nghệ là sẽ có cái form riêng.
Mình phải viết theo cái form của họ.
Còn và đối với cái nội dung thuyết minh
đề tài về độ dài.
À
Theo kinh nghiệm của cô,
thuyết minh đẹp ở đây,
nói chung là nó sẽ không có một cái.
Quy định đúng hết tất tất cả mọi trường
hợp nha các em,
nhưng mà cô nói về cái kinh nghiệm của cô
và cái mục tiêu của thuyết minh thì cái
đó với các thuyết minh đề tài hoặc là cái
phần đầu tư dự án á,
đầu tư dự án thì người ta cần có cái
thông tin chi tiết và người ta biết rằng.
Đầu tư và cái dự án đầu tư này nó đã đầu
tư hợp lý.
Bên cái thuyết minh đề tài cũng vậy,
cũng gần giống như vậy nhưng mà thuyết
minh đề tài á thì nó sẽ nhẹ hơn đối với
dự án đầu tư. Thí dụ,
ví dụ giống như cái dự án đầu tư mà trước
đây cô có quyết.
Cho trong cái dự án thành lập khoa đó,
hoặc là đang trường khoa bên bên khoa
mình đang muốn xin kinh phí để xây dựng
cái phòng lab thì cái dự án đầu tư thì
giống như là cái bên loại môn học của
mình á thì viết khá là dài nhưng em viết
rất là dài luôn.
À,
người ta cần minh chứng rồi em phải báo
giá rồi,
mình giống như lên một kế hoạch chi tiết
về cái hạ tầng đầu tư là lúc đó là người
ta sẽ duyệt về cái nội dung đầu tư của
mình đạt.
Thì người ta sẽ cho các em đầu tư đúng
cái hạ tầng đầu tư đó,
hạ tầng đầu tư mà mình cam kết và mình
vận hành ra sao.
Còn đối với các thuyết minh thì thuyết
minh là bạc thực hành là thuyết minh phần
mềm thì nó là đi theo.
Quá trình khác với mình,
phần mềm á là cái phần mềm mà thì mình đi
triển khai cái đối với đối với cái dự án
đầu tư thì nó nhẹ về cái phần kỹ thuật
hơn.
Nó nó nặng về cái phần mà em phải đầu tư
cái gì và vận hành ra sao nên cái thường
cái đó mình nói chi tiết thì người ta
thấy đầu tư hợp lý thì người ta thấy.
Bỏ tiền cho mình phát triển khoa hay là
phát triển còn thí nghiệm chẳng hạn,
còn đối với cái bài thực thuyết minh của
bài thực hành là thí sinh phần mềm thì
cái bên đối với cái dự án IT,
phần mềm của mình thì cái nặng của mình
là cái code.
Thực sự là cái báo cáo có chi tiết,
còn cái lúc đầu là người mình chưa có cài
đặt thì thường là nó sẽ chưa cài cho mọi
người hay nói là chưa cài là chưa biết
chuyện gì xảy ra,
chưa trải thực nghiệm hay chưa biết
chuyện gì xảy ra.
Và cái thuyết minh bài đối với cái phần
mềm này,
đương nhiên người ta sẽ không có bắt em.
Khai báo cái giá trị chi tiết.
Bắt buộc mình chắc chắn mình sẽ xây dựng
được cái chức năng phần mềm đó mà nó,
tại vì trong cái quá trình mình làm thì
nó sẽ có cái vấn đề là mình sẽ hiệu chỉnh
mà mình trao đổi với khách hàng để mình
sửa cái chức năng nó phù hợp nữa.
Và nhiều khi ứng dụng công nghệ mới thì.
Nó mang tính chất rủi ro nhưng em công
nghệ mới là không phải lúc nào áp dụng
cũng thành công nên trong cái thuyết minh
đề tài cũng không có bắt người ta mãi chi
tiết ra là cam kết được và cái thứ 2 là
chưa có chạy nên cũng chưa có gì để báo
cáo viết được trong cái thuyết minh cả.
Nên thường cái thuyết minh cái hệ thống
phần mềm mắt nó sẽ ngắn hơn so với một
cái báo cáo bình thường và và tại vì cái
mục tiêu á người ta chỉ muốn biết là em
có đủ năng lực làm hay không.
Em có kinh nghiệm làm cái này hay không.
Và nếu làm thì em biết cách làm nó không?
Và em sẽ căn cứ cái gì,
chỉ cần đạt cái đó thôi nên cái thường,
cái thuyết minh đề tài là người ta sẽ
không có trình bày chi tiết là tôi sẽ đã
làm được triển khai cái chức năng công
nghệ mới như thế nào.
Tại mình chưa có làm,
nhưng mà mình sẽ biết cách làm,
mình có kế hoạch phát triển phù hợp.
Nên khi mình biết cách viết nó khác nhau
thì thường cái đó thuyết minh phần mềm nó
sẽ ngắn hơn và nó ngắn thì tùy.
Nếu đối với các dự án mà ở trường cấp độ
trường tầm dưới 100 triệu thì thời kiến
thức minh mọi người mới anh em hay viết
với nhau thì tầm khoảng 20 trang.
Còn nếu mà đối với các thuyết minh thí dụ
của Đại học Quốc gia.
Kinh phí nhiều hơn đúng không?
Nó sẽ có các loại ABC, chẳng hạn,
nếu mà tối đa 200 triệu á thì thuộc
khoảng 3.30.
Còn nếu mà được đề tài B và CC mà lên tới
tỷ á thì thường nó sẽ nói dài hơn,
nó sẽ dài. Tại vì.
À yêu cầu sản phẩm nhiều hơn thì mình
phải có kế hoạch thực hiện dài hơn,
kế hoạch đạt thì nó dài hơn,
để có kinh phí nhiều hơn thì nó sẽ dài,
nhưng mà thường nó cũng tầm dưới khoảng
50 trang đổ lại thôi chứ nó không có dài
như một cái báo cáo đầy đủ cho cái.
Thì nó có thể dài hơn,
nhưng mà tại là cái thuyết minh chỉ là kế
hoạch thực hiện và cái kế hoạch dự kiến
minh làm thôi nên nó không thể nào dài
được.
Và các em phải phân biệt được cái này ha.
Thuyết minh không phải là cái em ngồi em
trình bày báo cáo.
Nó là cái kế hoạch dự kiến nguyện lại.
Đối với cái bài thực hành.
Rồi.
Hình như phương tiện.
Dạ vâng, em hiểu rồi, em cảm ơn cô.
Rồi nếu không có câu hỏi nào thêm vậy thì
cô thống nhắc lại nha cái ngày thi.
Ngày thi cho kem,
nhớ mình ngày hôm đó là các bạn bà đầy đủ
và lúc mình thi thì cô,
nếu có nhóm nào xung phong thì cô sẽ cho
nhóm tiếp xong trước,
còn không thì cô sẽ kêu theo thứ tự.
Và cô sẽ điểm danh.
Điểm danh trước khi mình thi nha các em
và thành phần đậu nếp,
nếu nào đủ rồi mình mới thi.
Còn nhóm nào chưa đủ thì đội thành viên
kia vô rồi mình mới thi nha các em.
Còn nói các bạn,
thành viên không tham gia luôn thì báo cô
là bạn nó vắng thì cô.
Các bạn cần đủ ra đủ hết rồi.
Còn bạn vắng thì báo cô vắng thì cô nói
lại rồi mình thi thôi. Ha.
Rồi thì buổi học mình sẽ kết thúc ở đây
nha, các em nhớ nộp à,
nhớ nộp bài nha các em.
Các em nhớ đọc bài nha.
Nộp đường lên chứ không mua nộp lên thực
hành giấy đổi.
À,
có đây có một số bạn hỏi bên máy tính
chat, mấy cái vấn đề này là cô hồi nãy,
cô báo với hướng dẫn và hướng dẫn chung
cho các nhóm rồi ha.
Còn cái buổi hôm nay là buổi học cuối,
buổi sau là buổi thi.
Bài tập viên trong bang mình sẽ không có
làm,
mình sẽ tích hợp vô hoàn thiện cái đó vô
cái bài đồ án với bài thực hành của mình
luôn chứ.
Phóng chất minh hả,
các em không có cần phải theo form em,
cái đó là cô để tại trước đây đúng không
cô dạy mấy bạn sinh viên chuyên bên chính
quy á mấy bạn còn trẻ,
mấy bạn chưa tiếp xúc cùng cái form bao
giờ thì các bạn muốn sinh.
Chú cô con cái form thực tế ra sao thì cô
để lên cho các bạn coi thôi.
Còn ở đây của mình mà mình không có cái
form không cố định nào cả hết á và cô có
cho các em cái gửi về mục luật á,
các em với thành một cái báo cáo theo cái
mục luật gợi ý hoặc là.
Tự hiệu chỉnh hay cái mục lục mà mình
muốn viết thôi.
Với hình cái báo cáo theo định dạng của
báo cáo chung của nhóm mình là được,
không cần theo cái form nào hết.